hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde die Düsseldorfer Bootsmesse kurz
auch Boot genannt ist die international
wichtigste bedeutsamste und größte Messe
für Boote und mega Yachten weltweit
dementsprechend sind da primär
Superreiche Leute Superreichen Anzügen
die sich Superreiche Yachten dort kaufen
wollen und wisst ihr da auch da war
und wisst ihr wenn diese dumme Person
hier mitgenommen hat geht raus Sandra
und ich
waren gestern am allerletzten Tag der
Bootsmesse vor Ort in Düsseldorf und
haben unseren Besuch der peinlicher
nicht hätte sein können auch noch auf
Twitch livestreamt und da ich euch diese
grinchhaftigkeit schlechte nicht
vorenthalten möchte seht ihr hier jetzt
ein Best of the stream Highlights
fallingboard
TV
ich glaube tatsächlich ich kaufe heute
Boot wie teuer ist das Boot ich sag dir
ganz ehrlich eine Million ab 69000 €
eine Million
perfekt hier für mich nicht dass die
Halle brennt Sandra Rauchverbot ne
siehst du hier auf alles
in unserem Livestream sagen warte ich
glaube mein Zollstock aus
ja klar
[Musik]
wir haben auch keine Kosten und Mühen
gescheute seht ihr ja schon an unseren
Stativen Lieblingswort wir haben keine
Kosten und Mühen gestartet ich liebe das
gespart Sprachen lernen Bubble ja wir
müssen gerade was drehen
in dem Video
genau ich habe die Titanic gefunden wir
haben tatsächlich
geplant ne die beste geht Original noch
eineinhalb Stunden das ist der letzte
Tag von zwei Wochen oder irgendwie so
das einzige was du hier cool findest
sind glaube ich so die Sitzmöglichkeiten
habe ich so das Gefühl wir haben nämlich
tatsächlich
gefragt was denkst du Sandra wie viel
wiegt das Boot hier links
Fragen ich sag eine Tonne einmal Sandy
also da werden wir nie wieder da Yacht
kommen
82 Jahre gibt es schon
was machen Twitch Livestream ich weiß
das ja nicht wenn ich jetzt mein Arsch
zeigen würde würden wir dann gesperrt
werden
gib mal zum Pool und fragt ob man dort
Döner bestellen kann ich liebe meinen
Community die Boot ist glaube ich die
größte internationale yachtmesse
Deutschlands
Lilly schreibt dir gerade die ganze Zeit
sie wartet die ganze Zeit darauf dass
ich hier ins Mikrofon vorzu hallo wir
sind ja auf einer sehr ernstzunehmenden
seriösen Bootsmesse eine Stunde
[Musik]
Gelände denn
Angela Merkel Spieler
wie heißen die noch mal Düsseldorf Allee
Düsseldorf
wie teuer ist der Eintritt hier
überhaupt gewesen 50 Euro
pro Stunde
ich sehe aus wie ein
wo geht man die Teller ab
aber
[Musik]
wo kommen wir denn wieder runter ich
fühle mich wieder Papst ich esse gerade
die ganze Zeit so lauten Käsebrötchen
ich habe ich bin der Laktoseintoleranz
[Musik]
Wissenschaft oder ähnlich geworden
uns vor allem
ähm könnt ihr mir mal ganz kurz
paar Fragen reinschreiben nun kann man
hat sich komplett gehört ne
du pinkelt hast
okay ich auch nicht es sind echt viele
Leute die auch die man kennt eine rewi
lass mich in Ruhe grüßen
deine Mama gerade gefunden die Grüße
manchmal wenn ich morgens gerade
aufwache sind meine Augen noch nicht so
ganz fokussiert aber nach einer kurze
Zeit sich dann klarer
wir nehmen Videoaufnahme
weißt du mit so einem Auto sehe ich mich
so
geil
heute sitze
so machen möchte dass man es
interessiert dann Sandra nimmt der
Netzteil 5 Euro probiert weil sie pleite
ist leider
so an du spinnst
das ist dick das ist dick oh mann die
alle Bilder von unserer Yacht verstehen
nicht
drauf oder ist es
hallo nein okay kein Problem kauf mir
eine andere
[Musik]
Frage ob wir da irgendwo drauf dürfen
habe ich glaube wir sind halt ein
bisschen zu spät leider
ist das groß ich hätte mit allem
gerechnet aber nicht mit so einer Größe
ne glaubt immer
noch aber das ist zu hoher Traum komm
wo sind wir wir kommen aus Bayern sind
immer reiche Leute
gehen gar nicht moin
ja wenn du uns Boot kauft dann
hallo
keiner sagt mir hallo no Joker werden
noch niemand Hallo gesagt
kann man bei euch noch auf die Boote
einmal gucken auch nicht okay also es
sind tatsächlich auf jeden Boden sind
Leute drauf aber wir dürfen halt nicht
davon auch noch drauf gehen ist
wahrscheinlich auch schon
der Besitzer ist schon okay der muss
schon wegfahren damit jetzt möchten Sie
uns ein Boot verkaufen
also ich sehe hier kein U-Boot
sorry
in Italien werden_lo
[Musik]